als Parteivorsitzender hat Christian
Lindner die FDP in die Ampelkoalition
geführt danach ging es für seine Partei
erst einmal bergab fünf Landtagswahlen
hat die FDP verloren und auch bei den
kommenden Wahlen in Bayern und Hessen
sieht es nicht gut aus hat Christian
Lindner die Liberalen in die falsche
Koalition geführt und wie geht er um mit
dauerzoff in der Ampel und
profilierungsdrang der FDP darüber
spreche ich heute mit dem
fdp-parteivorsitzenden und
Bundesfinanzminister in seiner
Wahlheimat Berlin herzlich willkommen
zum ZDF sommerinterview
[Musik]
ich grüße Sie herzlich willkommen beim
ZDF sommerinterview freue mich sehr
vielen Dank für die Einladung wir
treffen uns hier in ihre Wahlheimat die
auch ganz nah dran ist an ihrem
Arbeitsplatz richtig da ist das
Finanzministerium und es ist auch nur
ein Katzensprung zum Kanzleramt das
trifft sich heute glaube ich ganz gut
denn sie haben heute direkt nach unserem
Interview wir zeichnen am Nachmittag auf
noch eine Krisensitzung haben wir gehört
im Kanzleramt zum Thema
Kindergrundsicherung wenn sie da
ausgeplaudert ja dafür sind wir
natürlich da das rauszubekommen dafür
sind wir da das rauszubekommen da
sollten Sie heute noch mal mit Frau Haus
und mit Herrn Scholz über die
Kindergrundsicherung reden wenn es nach
ihnen geht ist das das letzte
Krisengespräch dann zu diesem Thema es
gibt keine Krisengespräche zu dem Thema
sondern es gibt Arbeitsgespräche um ein
Vorhaben zu konkretisieren und ich hoffe
dass wir sehr bald
erreichen dass die bestehenden
Leistungen für Kinder zusammengeführt
werden und dass alle die ein recht haben
sie erhalten dass wir auf der anderen
Seite aber
einfachen Anreiz setzen dass Menschen
sich auch um Arbeit bemühen und im
Integration bemühen müssen und wenn das
gelingt wird ein gutes Vorhaben sie
sagen jetzt ganz gelassen es gibt gar
kein Krisengespräch gehen auf die
Inhalte von außen sah das ein bisschen
anders aus da kochten die Emotionen in
den Aussagen wieder hoch meine nicht wie
jetzt auf die Details können wir gleich
noch mal eingehen wenn wir mal auf die
Stimmungslage schauen was haben Sie denn
für einen Eindruck wie nah ist Olaf
Scholz davor mal auf den Tisch zu haben
gemacht worden zu sprechen
es kann ja Demokratie keine Machtworte
geben weil man kommt zusammen für
gemeinsame Vorhaben und es geht ja darum
Gutes für unser Land zu bewirken in
diesem konkreten Fall geht es darum die
Lebenschancen von Kindern und
Jugendlichen zu verbessern in unserem
Land hängt die Herkunft aus der oder
bestimmt die Herkunft aus dem Elternhaus
immer noch sehr stark den Platz den man
im Leben einnimmt das muss verändert
werden der Schlüssel dafür ist aber
Bildung ist Integration ist
Sprachförderung das sind die Details
über die wir nachher noch mal sprechen
können jetzt halten was kurz und gehen
direkt dahin wo wir uns dann zum
Sprechen gerne
[Musik]
Helena Kindergrundsicherung war gerade
schon das Thema wenn ich richtig gezählt
habe haben sie dazu schon vier Sitzungen
diese Woche gehabt mit Ihnen Frau Paus
und Herrn Scholz und wenn man heute dazu
setzt wenn man heute dazu rechnet und da
Kanzler hat gestern noch einmal davon
gesprochen dass eine Lösung bis nächste
Woche gibt Gide Jensen ihre
Bundestagsabgeordnete hat aber gesagt
nein bis nächste Woche Meseberg Kabinett
das war immer so eine Zielmarke die
genannt wurde das reicht nicht wir
müssen noch viel länger prüfen wissen
Sie schon wie sauer der Kanzler darüber
ist wenn es noch länger dauert
das eine und das andere steht gar nicht
in einem Widerspruch ich rechne damit
dass wir sehr kurzfristig eine Einigung
über die Eckpunkte haben was getan
werden soll
ich will jetzt nicht selber Termine
nennen sondern ich sage sehr rasch aber
danach gibt es ja auch sehr viel
technisch was noch geklärt werden muss
dann werden Verbände und Länder
beteiligt und dann wird es erst ein
fertigen Gesetzentwurf geben der dann an
den Bundestag geht und insofern steht
beides nicht im Widerspruch wir werden
rasch eine grundlegende Einigung und
Verständigung auf die Eckpunkte haben
das gesamte Verfahren wird noch etwas
brauchen
bundestagsabgeordnet ist natürlich die
Frage in welcher Funktion sie sich
geäußert hat denn üblich ist
ja eigentlich dass sie im Kabinett haben
sie gerade auch erklärt das Gesetz
aushandeln dann geht es in den Bundestag
und dann wird es dort eben verhandelt
warum versucht die Fraktion ihnen da
jetzt gerade die Verantwortung aus der
Hand zu nehmen haben sie nicht mit dem
SPD-Vorsitzenden der nicht dem Kabinett
an gehört auch schon Sommer Interviews
gemacht
ja lassen Sie uns zum nächsten Thema
wechseln weil der Bundestag und die
Fraktionen sind nicht befasst damit sie
äußert sich als frei gewählte
Abgeordnete ohne im Prozess zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt schon mitzuwirken sie haben es
eben schon mal angesprochen in der
Begrüßung was Ihnen besonders wichtig
ist da sind sie auch noch mal
eingegangen auf die Herkunft auf die
Anzahl derer die eben dort nicht
deutscher Herkunft sind ich wollte ganz
gerne mit Ihnen einmal ganz kurz zur
Klärung beitragen für diejenigen die
nicht ganz tief in der Materie drin sind
wenn sie sagen
wenn sie sagen sie wollen da gezielter
Vorgehen dann sagen sie doch übersetzt
für alle
sie wollen armen Familien aktuell nicht
mehr Staatsgeld direkt überweisen ist
das richtig das ist korrekt wir haben
eine fünfköpfige Familie beispielsweise
die nicht arbeitet die in diesem Jahr
gut 37 38.000 € vom Steuerzahler bereits
bekommt der Grund für die Armut der
Kinder liegt dort in der fehlenden
Arbeit für die Eltern
vielleicht in fehlenden
Sprachkenntnissen auch der Eltern
begründet und deshalb sage ich hier um
die Situation der Kinder und Jugendliche
zu verbessern geht es nicht um einen
höheren sozialtransfer denn da ist schon
viel Geld im Spiel und wir müssen jetzt
etwas tun dass die Eltern integriert
werden dass sie in den Arbeitsmarkt
kommen und auf der anderen Seite dass
wir bei den Kindern und Jugendlichen die
Kita die Schule verbessern und dafür
sorgen dass kein Kind auf einen
Schulausflug verzichten muss weil das
Geld fehlt
Chancengleichheit vor allem damit sorgen
sie wenn sie da so investieren dafür
dass Kinder später alleine aus eigener
Kraft gut zurechtkommen Frau Paus hat ja
jetzt etwas vor das den Kindern aktuell
direkt das Leben verbessert wenn es den
Familien dann mit etwas mehr Geld besser
geht warum wollen sie nicht beides tun
ich möchte nicht den Anreiz reduzieren
sich am Arbeit zu bemühen den Kindern
geht es auch besser wenn die Eltern
einen Beruf ausüben wir haben in
Deutschland
wir haben einen akute Notfall sozusagen
knapp 38.000 Euro ist bereits keine
Notfallversorgung mehr sondern da ist
das Existenzminimum gesichert bei denen
die nicht arbeiten wir wecken hier den
Eindruck dass es das ist dort um
Verelendung geht das gibt es in unserem
Sozialstaat nicht sondern wir
engagieren uns bereits sehr stark mit
vielen vielen Milliarden Euro meine
Position ist hier eindeutig was das
Absicherungsniveau mit Geldtransfer
angeht haben wir das Wesentliche in
Deutschland bereits getan jetzt müssen
wir dafür sorgen dass Menschen arbeiten
die Menschen werden nämlich gesucht und
auf der anderen Seite das Kinder und
Jugendliche eine gute Ausbildung
bekommen und dass sie soziale Teilhabe
Stichwort Schulausflug haben da ist ihre
Position klar geworden die Frau von Frau
Pause ist auch klar sie stoßen da
frontal aufeinander und zwar seit
Monaten und der Streit ist größtenteils
auch öffentlich ausgetragen worden
zumindest in den Spitzen wo die Stimmung
wirklich richtig schlecht gewesen ist
wollen oder können sie und die Grünen
sich da gar nicht mehr anders
auseinandersetzen was mir zu einer
maximalen Konfrontation ich habe keine
Konfrontation in die Öffentlichkeit
getragen das weiß ich getan habe ist
zweierlei zum einen habe ich darauf
hingewiesen dass es einen Zusammenhang
zwischen Kinderarmut und Einwanderung
nach Deutschland gibt das sind die
nüchternen Zahlen jetzt geht es um den
Streit es geht um die Frage der
Auseinandersetzung hat aber ja zu einer
Reaktion geführt manche wollten ja die
Zahlen nicht glauben oder nicht die Zahl
in der Öffentlichkeit thematisieren aber
diesen Zusammenhang muss man ansprechen
und zum anderen verweise ich auf den
Koalitionsvertrag und bitte um
Vertragstreue im Koalitionsvertrag ist
nichts über eine weitere
leistungsausweitung im Sinne von
finanziellen Transfers gesagt also da
verweise ich noch das was wir verabredet
haben trotzdem noch die Frage wo klären
Sie das klären Sie das hinter den
Kulissen oder davor der Streit der
scheint bei ihnen ja mittlerweile schon
Methode zu haben die
Kindergrundsicherung ist nicht das erste
Thema bei dem es nach außen getragen
wird und vor der Öffentlichkeit
ausgetragen wird das heizungsgesetz das
hat Monate lang die Öffentlichkeit
beschäftigt wegen der aus
Auseinandersetzungen und das Land auch
verunsichert da ist der Eindruck dass
das regierungsprinzip mittlerweile ein
maximales gegeneinander ist und die
Auswirkungen sehen wir ein Umfragen im
Politbarometer haben 74% der Befragten
gesagt die Stimmung in der Ampel ist
eher schlecht und 83 Prozent sagen bei
der Lösung von Problemen geht es eher
nicht voran vorangeht währenddessen nur
mit den Umfragewerten der AFD und
deshalb nochmal die Frage warum reißen
sie sich denn nicht mehr zusammen und
verhandeln die Dinge wie am Anfang der
Ampel hinter den Kulissen die Frage
müssen Sie nicht an mich richten ich
habe nicht ja aber trotzdem lassen sie
mich meine Position darstellen bitte es
war doch so dass die Familienministerin
das wachstumschancengesetz blockiert hat
wegen der Kindergrundsicherung und das
war öffentlicher Streit das ging nicht
von mir aus
ich halte es nein das ist ja eine andere
unabhängige Partei und ein
eigenständiges Ministerium und eine
selbst ganz bewusste Kollegin da habe
ich keinen Einfluss darauf aber eins
will ich schon sagen
der öffentliche Eindruck ist nicht
zufriedenstellend wir können über Dinge
wie Kinder Grundsicherung und
Klimaschutz nur sprechen wenn wir ein
starkes wirtschaftliches Fundament haben
die Voraussetzung lassen Sie mich doch
bitte meinen Gedanken kurz ausführen
Blick auf die AFD beantworten bitte
geben Sie mir die Gelegenheit dazu die
Voraussetzung für
soziale Ausgaben und für Klimaschutz ist
ein stabiles wirtschaftliches Fundament
wir haben gerade eine schlechte
wirtschaftliche Situation und die
Menschen erwarten dass die Politik alles
tut für Wachstum und Beschäftigung damit
wir uns soziale Aufgaben und Klimaschutz
leisten und beim heizungsgesetz besteht
der gleiche Zusammenhang es wäre fatal
gewesen wenn wir ein Gesetz beschlossen
hätten das nur die Wärmepumpe sieht dass
die Menschen gezwungen hätte die Gebäude
zu sanieren wo es nicht wirtschaftlich
ist Menschen hatten das das Gefühl jetzt
kommt der Staat noch in den
Heizungskeller und macht mir Vorgaben
und deshalb war es notwendig dass die
FDP das wirtschaftlich vernünftig und
physikalisch möglich ausgestattet haben
gerade gesagt der äußere Eindruck ist
nicht zufriedenstellend tatsächlich
tatsächlich
machen sie sich in der FDP in der FDP
jetzt müssen sie mich aber kurz lassen
in der FDP machen sie sich nämlich
tatsächlich Gedanken darüber wie das
nach außen ankommt und ob Ihnen die
Ampel als solche gut tut Christiane
hübscher meine Kollegin hat mal
zusammengefasst worum es da geht
es war ein Projekt zu dem Christian
Lindner nicht wirklich nein sagen konnte
wir haben gesagt wir wollen mehr
Fortschritt Wagen und weil das Signal
zur Legende werden sollte musste es auch
für ihn schnell gehen vieles wurde im
Koalitionsvertrag nicht ausverhandelt
der Preis dauert die FDP stürzt in
Umfragen ab verliert an Profil und fünf
Landtagswahlen in Folge
die Ampelkoalition ist politische
Vergewaltigung der FDP so rumort es aus
der Partei nach der desaströsen Berlin
Wahl steuert Lindner um ab jetzt gilt
die Partei zuerst der Ton wird scharf
gestellt also lieber die
Positionslichter der FDP anschalten wird
ein modernes nicht links Deutschland es
folgt der versucht der Profilschärfung
die FDP stoppt das Verbrenner aus in
Europa der Robert können sich gehackt
legen die Grünen als Gegner damit
stabilisieren sich die Umfragen im Bund
etwas doch schon die nächsten
Landtagswahlen Drohnen wieder im Fiasko
zu enden jetzt haben wir gerade beim
Zuschauen darüber geredet dass sie sich
mittlerweile auf sieben Prozent schon
stabilisiert haben das sind zwei Prozent
mehr als die fünf die bei in unseren
Umfragen der niedrig wird gewesen sind
aber sie haben es gesehen die nächsten
Landtagswahlen in Hessen und in Bayern
die sind auch wieder sehr knapp für Sie
da sagen die Umfragen für Hessen sechs
Prozent für Bayern 4%
vor wenn sie sich das so anschauen die
Zahlen die wirklich knapp über der 5%
Hürde sind haben sie dann manchmal den
Gedanken die Reißleine zu ziehen weil
sie doch in der falschen Koalition sind
nein die Koalition ist schwierig das
kann niemanden überraschen die drei
Parteien haben völlig unterschiedliche
Programme meine Partei setzt stark auf
Freiheit wir setzen auf private
Initiative wir wollen Wohlstand erst mal
erwirtschaften bevor wir ihn verteilen
sind sie zufrieden und
deshalb ist es völlig klar dass es ganz
unterschiedliche politische Positionen
gibt für mich entscheidend ist die
wesentliche Umfrage die 2025 am Wahltag
stattfindet und bis dahin machen wir
unsere Arbeit die Menschen ja verlieren
sie vielleicht noch weitere Wahlen sie
sind in Australien in drei Bundesländern
schon aus dem Bundestag raus aus dem
Bundestag aus dem Landtag rausgewählt
worden in zwei Bundesländern haben die
Wähler sie aus der Regierung rausgewählt
noch mal die Frage muten Sie Ihre Partei
dann nicht zu viel zu auf dieser
die Strecke bis 25 erst geht es um das
Land und wir haben eine staatspolitische
Verantwortung in der Bundesregierung und
wir haben eine Verantwortung
gegenüber den Menschen und da gibt es
einmal ein auf- und ab in Umfragen und
es gibt auch einmal wahlabende nach
einer Landtagswahl die wünscht man sich
anders aber in der jetzigen Situation
entscheidend ist was anderes wir müssen
die Inflation bekämpfen und deshalb muss
die Schuldenbremse geachtet werden sie
wird jeden Tag hart umstritten jeden Tag
Kontroverse wir müssen die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung voranbringen
jeden Tag wird über Steuererhöhungen
gesprochen
es geht ja nicht immer Umfragen von
Parteien sondern wie ist die Situation
im Land die Menschen sind ja auch darum
ob sie ihre Mitglieder mitnehmen
Inhalte im Zentrum stehen und ich glaube
in der Sache erreichen wir Gutes selbst
wenn es einmal Umfragen und Wahlen gibt
die nicht zufrieden trotzdem wird ihre
Partei in Teilen unruhig Frank
Schaeffler auch Bundestagsabgeordneter
sagt und das zitiere ich mal wenn die
Grünen die Schuldenbremse in Frage
stellen und die Steuern erhöhen wollen
dann stellt sich die Koalitionsfrage sie
stellt sich ja natürlich wenn wir
gezwungen werden würden die
Schuldenbremse auszusetzen oder die
Steuern zu erhöhen dann würde sich die
Koalitionsfrage stellen aber niemand tut
das das ist für sie die rote Linie das
steht im Koalitionsvertrag und es wäre
angesichts der wirtschaftlichen
Entwicklung jetzt doch wirklich unklug
wir würden noch die Steuerlast erhöhen
die Betriebe leiden unter den hohen
Energiepreisen die müssen runter aber
statt dass wir da Fortschritte machen
diskutieren wir über Steuererhöhung das
wäre mit der FDP nicht zu machen aber
bevor sie daraus eine Meldung machen mit
der Koalitionsfrage will ich ganz klar
sagen
dass tatsächlich es gibt die
öffentlichen Äußerungen von SPD und
Grünen aber ich kann nicht erkennen dass
es ernsthafte Versuche gibt hier von
unseren Festlegungen im Koalition Antrag
abzuweichen insofern Theorie sie
markieren es theoretisch genau sie haben
jetzt gerade gesagt die Verantwortung
für das Land wir haben ich habe ihnen
eben auch versprochen wir sprechen über
Wirtschaft denn sie bekommen da ja
tatsächlich wenn Sie über diese Themen
sprechen von zwei Seiten gleich Druck
die einen sagen Christian Lindner spart
nicht genug der hat einen teureren
Bundeshaushalt vorgelegt als 2019 er hat
noch andere Projekte in die Milliarden
fließen an der Seite also Sparmeister
ist nicht das sollte so nicht sein und
die anderen sagen wenn schon Geld
rausgeht dann doch bitte so viel das ist
der schwerst angeschlagenen deutschen
Wirtschaft tatsächlich auch schnell
hilft sie stehen irgendwo in der Mitte
fehlt in der Mut sich für eine Seite zu
entscheiden nein ich entscheide mich für
den richtigen Weg der richtige Weg ist
die Bekämpfung der Inflation das ist die
größte Gefahr und wenn die Zentralbank
die EZB die Zinsen anzieht wäre es
töricht ökonomisch falsch wir würden mit
Politik auf dagegen Subventionen setzen
dann würde das die Bekämpfung der
Inflation verlängern und verteuern der
Schaden wäre viel größer und auf der
anderen Seite müssen wir Geld für das
richtige einsetzen öffentliche
Investitionen im Bereich Digitalisierung
und Infrastruktur ja aber nicht mehr
Umverteilung das machen wir das aus
meiner Sicht der richtige Weg damit die
Wirtschaft vorankommt Frau bei einer die
müssen wir aber noch etwas ganz anderes
tun nämlich verzichten auf immer mehr
bürokratische Gesetze und das will ich
ganz offen sagen ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen das bevor die deutsche
Wirtschaft Fahrt aufgenommen hat wir
noch irgendwelche zusätzlichen
bürokratischen oder finanziellen
Verpflichtungen beschließen dann gibt es
auch Teile des Koalitionsvertrages die
sind tatsächlich aus der Zeit gefallen
und dann müssen alle ein Einsehen haben
dass wir erst wieder wirtschaftlich
gewissermaßen Traktion aufnehmen können
bevor es neue Belastungen geben kann
nicht gerne hören wir schauen mal auf
Bewertungen von außen der Internationale
Währungsfonds sagt Deutschland ist das
einz G7 Land dessen Wirtschaft schrumpft
der ifo-Geschäftsklimaindex der rutscht
auch stetig wieder ab zuletzt im Juli
wieder also von außen ist die
Betrachtung ehrlich gesagt verheerend
und der Economist renommierte
Wirtschaftszeitschrift der titelte sogar
ist Deutschland wieder der kranke Mann
Europas und das in einem in einer mit
einer Bundesregierung in der die FDP mit
regierte sie bleiben auf Kurs überlegen
Sie nicht mal ob sie dann doch umdenken
müssen
aber diejenigen die sie gerade zitiert
haben die empfehlen doch gerade eine
Politik für die ich eintreten die
empfehlen noch gerade Deutschland muss
die Bürokratie lassen reduzieren deshalb
kann es keine neuen Vorhaben geben die
die Bürokratie lassen die die zitiert
haben die empfehlen doch teilweise wir
sollen die Steuern reduzieren deshalb
das wachstumsschancengesetzt und mal für
den Laien gesprochen sie sie suggerieren
damit für viele die nichts davon
verstehen dass die Krise vorbei ist man
muss jetzt streng bleiben damit es
wieder besser wird wie erklären sie das
den Leuten die die Krise jetzt erst so
richtig zu spüren bekommen mit
Lebensmittelpreisen mit steigenden
Energiepreisen mit allem was da auf die
Menschen einprasselt ich suggeriere
überhaupt nicht dass die Krise vorbei
ist aber sie hat ihren Charakter
verändert wir haben jetzt keinen
Nachfrageausfall wie während der
Pandemie weil alles geschlossen war wir
haben jetzt Inflation die Preise steigen
und damit die Inflation bekämpft wird
gibt es und so sind auch die
Empfehlungen der Institutionen die sie
gerade zitiert haben ist die Empfehlung
Schluss mit der Politik auf Punkt die es
während der Pandemie gab ihr müsst die
öffentlichen Haushalte wieder in Ordnung
bringen das ist der Beitrag des Staates
zur Bekämpfung der Inflation von genau
den Institutionen die sie gerade zitiert
haben und auf der anderen Seite müssen
wir dafür sorgen dass die Kaufkraft
erhalten bleibt dass die Arbeitsplätze
sicher sind und dass unsere Betriebe in
England investieren was tun wir dafür es
muss die Bürokratie Last reduziert
werden die Energiepreise müssen sehen
können ich wäre zum Beispiel offen für
eine Senkung der Stromsteuer ich bin
entschieden dafür dass wir schnell mehr
energieversorgungskapazität aufbauen
weil das die Preise reduziert damit
stärken wir die wirtschaftliche
Situation nichts mit Subventionen auf
Pump und das klingt danach als hätten
sie noch vieles aus zur Fechten mit
ihrem Koalitionspartnern wir werden
beobachten wie das funktioniert erstmal
herzlichen Dank für das Gespräch ich
danke Ihnen sehr
das war unser zdf-sommer-interview mit
dem Bundesfinanzminister und
Parteivorsitzenden der FDP Christian
Lindner und in der kommenden Woche
treffe ich den bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten und Vorsitzenden der
CSU Markus Söder ihnen herzlichen Dank
fürs zuschauen und einen schönen Abend
[Musik]